But,
one of the very important things to
learn from a book this
is the way that the scholars
traditionally set up their books, the
order that they put their books in. And
most of the books of fiqh
follow
the general method that al-Bukhari
rahimahullah set up his Sahih.
And so,
the way that the author set this up and
the way that most of the scholars
set this up
is that, for instance, wudu.
He will begin with mentioning the ruling
on wudu,
right? That it is obligatory, that it is
you know, rafa' al-hadath is one of the
conditions of salah, etc. And then he
goes into mentioning the ideal wudu.
what is the most complete form
of this
wudu that the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam made? And since this book has
very little commentary and is mostly
just the ruling and its evidence, the
ruling and its evidence, the ruling and
its evidence,
he mentions the narration of Uthman,
radiyallahu anhu, which is cited as the
most It's the most widely cited
narration when
mentioning or painting a picture of
the most idyllic
wudu of the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam.
And so, that's going to tell us what the
best wudu is.
It doesn't distinguish
in that part when we are mentioning the
idyllic
version of whatever the act of
worship is in this case will do.
It won't He won't distinguish between
that which is a sunnah, that which is a
condition, that which is obligatory,
that which is mustahab. He doesn't make
that distinction.
He's saying this is the most ideal wudu.
This is how the prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam made it in the most
complete and ideal fashion.
Then he begins to break down the wudu
into the general
categorizations that the scholars have
traditionally used. Conditions, pillars,
obligations,
, sunan, or that which is mustahab,
that which is preferable, and then goes
into its opposites. So, those things
which break a person's wudu, nullifiers
of wudu, mawani' al-wudu,
etc.
And so in this case he mentions the
narration of Uthman.
And then he mentions the conditions of
wudu.
And we mentioned that of these three
conditions that he mentioned,
the strongest of them, which have all
been agreed on, is an-niyyah, is
intention.
And
then he mentions at-tasmiyah
wal-muwalat. At-tasmiyah saying
bismillah.
This is obligatory ma' adh-dhikr, if a
person remembers.
And then muwalat is actually part of the
obligations of wudu. And we mentioned
that wudu has how many obligations?
Six. Six obligations.
The first is
washing the face entirely, including the
mouth and nose. Number two,
the hands and arms to include the
elbows. Number three,
wiping over the head to include the
ears. Number four, the feet to include
the ankles. Number five, succession that
this be made successively all together.
And number six, that this
be made in this order. It has to be made
in this order, which we will get into
inshallah ta'ala. So, the author then
starts with
The
obligations of wudu, and we mentioned
yesterday why
the scholars traditionally count these
as obligations and not as pillars.
So, he says
The first is washing the face
to include the mouth and nose. When we
look at the verse in the Quran,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala doesn't
mention the mouth and nose
in a specific sense. He said
He says, "Wash your faces." This is what
he begins with.
However,
we know that this verse includes the
mouth and nose.
So, if we were to say,
"What is the definition
of the face
in this context in the Quran?" We would
say it is the face to include the mouth
and nose. How do we know that?
Well, when we look at the sunnah
and we gather all of the narrations
that mention the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam washing his face for
wudu,
we find that he has never failed
to to do the mouth and nose with his
face, ever.
Ever. He was never narrated explicitly
to have made wudu
without the mouth and nose.
So, what do we understand this to mean?
We understand that he understood that
when Allah said, "Wash your faces," it
was to include what?
The mouth and the nose.
[Silence]
So,
if someone were to say it's not
mentioned in the Quran, incorrect. It
is. The Prophet
understood it to be mentioned in the
Quran.
And we have a principle that this has to
work on, and that is
that how does the Prophet
communicate to us
and in turn fulfill the commands of
Allah?
How does he communicate to us that
something is not obligatory?
Well, sometimes he will just say it's
not obligatory.
For instance,
a man asked him about fasting
in travel.
He said, "If you want to fast, fast, and
if you don't want to, you don't have
to." This articulates very clearly that
it's not obligatory.
But in other more subtle ways is that he
will not do it on occasion, at least
once.
Something is is mustahab, it's not
obligatory.
At least once
in his
fulfillment of this command.
He will not do it. Why? To articulate
that it is
mustahab.
So for instance, sujud at tilawa.
Making sujud for the
verses of sujud in the Quran.
We have most of the time
90% of the time
if he recites a verse that has a sajdah
in it or
he is listening to someone, listening,
not hearing, listening
to someone reciting
a verse that has a tilawa that has a
sajdah in it,
he would make sujud.
But then he has some instances where he
would not make sujud.
For instance, it is not the sunnah
to make sujud
in reciting Surah as-Sajdah on the Fajr
salah of Jumu'.
In the Fajr salah of Jumu', usually he
would recite in the first rak' Surah
as-Sajdah.
And in the second rak'
Surah al-Insan.
However, he was never narrated to have
made sujud during that salah.
And there's other instances as well.
Iqra Surah al-Inshiqaq fil Isha wal
yasjud ila akhirih. There are a number
of incidents where he would recite Surah
as-Sajdah or a sajdah and not make
sujud.
What does this articulate?
It articulates that this is not
obligatory.
This is mustahab.
So, if al-madmada wal-istinshaq
if the mouth and nose were obligatory,
we would have to have at least what?
At least one instance
where he made wudu
without making al-madmada wal-istinshaq
for us to come to the conclusion
that it is what? Mustahab.
Because
many of us have heard
the principle
that is
the actions of the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam,
not his words, his actions,
they do not articulate obligation.
[Silence]
This is a point that many don't know
about this principle, and that is that
the scholars of fiqh generally agree
that
the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam's
actions alone
do not articulate obligation. If he does
something
and he's observed doing it and he
doesn't command it,
it doesn't necessarily mean that it's
obligatory for us to do it.
Right?
for instance, kissing the black
stone
when a person makes tawaf.
He did it.
And in other narrations, he commanded it
be done, but we know that it's not
obligatory.
Right? Because we have other evidences
where this wasn't done.
However,
this doesn't mean that if he does
something
and every time he does it, he does it
this way and never fails to do it except
in this way, this does articulate
obligation.
Meaning in every time, how many years
did he make wudu? I mean,
over a decade, right? Of making wudu.
Making wudu in travel, in residence, in
sick, healthy, right?
Never once was he narrated to have made
wudu and failed to make
and failed to rinse his mouth and nose.
Never one time in all those years.
What do we surmise from this? What do we
conclude from this? That is part of
wudu. It's obligatory. Just he
never failed to wash his face, or he
never failed to wash his arms, or he
never failed to wipe over his head, or
he never failed to wash his feet, or he
never made wudu out of order.
The order that's mentioned in the Quran.
Or he never made wudu in parts.
Right?
Wash his face at home and then wash his
arms an hour later and then wash wipe
over his head half an hour later and
then
wash his feet an hour later. This never
happened. So, this means what? That
these things are a part of wudu, an
integral part of wudu. May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
[Arabic recitation]
fix the
ceiling so I'll do that.
[Arabic recitation]
and my sofa
I I think it was maybe the image or
something the
the couch that was there.
I think the water got on it.
[Arabic recitation]